what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so after completing our video on
the origin of gilt Hulk a lot of you
guys really seem to be interested in
that whole thing I thought we were kind
of done with Incredible Hulk stuff but I
guess not I guess that's always just
more whole more off but this is the
origin of infernal Hulk this is actually
kind of a cool story because this is a
story called identity wars and identity
wars it's like this three-part limited
series that featured spider-man Deadpool
in the Incredible Hulk now originally I
was just going to do the Incredible Hulk
portion but it's a continual story it's
not one of these you know three-issue
one-shots or anything along those lines
and so what this really does is it
essentially picks up with just like
spider-man and Deadpool and the
Incredible Hulk and they're all kind of
thrust into the same location and the
reason why is because of the fact that
spider-man again is at this point in his
life where he's part of horizon labs
remember we talked about that and our
videos are run on the amazing spider-man
before all-new all-different marvel but
eventually he was inducted as part of
horizon labs which is just the think
tank for people who were extremely smart
and they put their intelligence to task
for just making things that make the
world a better place but horizon labs
had also been a place that was targeted
by a handful of criminals they'd
actually hired Deadpool for the purpose
of breaking in and basically accessing
other dimensions and the reason why is
because of the fact that within horizon
labs was just this massive portal this
massive bridge to other universes now
the idea behind this is that it was just
something that people have horizon labs
were working on it doesn't really seem
like it had a purpose or it was supposed
to serve any unique purpose we know that
it does just because of the fact of the
things that go on and what we saw in our
spider-man story that it basically
allowed people to jump in and out of
dimensions of different things along
those lines but the fact remains here
that deadpool being hired was just for
the purpose of jumping from one reality
to the next in order to find like gold
and precious jewels that was it and it's
actually not a bad criminal scheme to
like jump through other dimensions and
then steal stuff and then jump back
because they'd never find you like you
would just disappear into the multiverse
and it's not a bad idea one of the funny
things that Deadpool references is New
Mutants issue number 98 which would be
certified 9.8 that's the best you can
have when it comes to a
and comic story and actually has that I
saw and get it signed by Rob Liefeld I
was so jealous but it's kind of one of
the fighting things new name is number
98 for those guys who don't know that
was the first appearance of Deadpool in
Marvel Comics it was a fun little easter
egg but in the middle of all this what
we end up finding out is that Bruce
Banner had been contracted by horizon
labs to work on a small side project so
he ended up being caught by one of these
criminals when he was snooping around
trying to figure out what was going on
and so we basically end up having Spider
Man Deadpool and The Incredible Hulk all
kind of thrown in one location now what
is there going on is in the middle of
this giant fight when the Hulk manifest
and starts tearing things up it
ultimately results in this portal
activating and then basically being
yanked through but a cool thing about
this is that they're sort of dispersed
they're sort of split into different
locations and they all end up going
about their own business and we actually
just end up running into what's called
The Amazing Spider now one of the things
to keep in mind when it comes to Spider
Man as a character and it's really like
this for the most popular characters
there are different iterations are
usually explored pretty well by
different writers just because of the
fact that fans at least as far as I'm
aware from my own perspective and
stories that I've seen fans like seeing
alternate reality takes on characters
because it gives them a break away from
what they've been reading so far but the
cool thing about this is that we end up
having this version of spider-man this
alternate reality version of Peter
Parker it seems to more or less be kind
of ill now we will find out there's a
little more going on with them than what
initially meets the eye the whole
concept behind them is actually derived
from the inheritors which we'll talk
about here's a little bit but in the
face of the fact that this also that
reality version of Peter Parker is more
or less sick but the main Marvel Peter
Parker takes up his stead but the cool
thing about this is that there are no
other superheroes in this universe all
the superheroes are basically left and
retired and more or less walked away and
the first inclination of this comes from
the main Marvel Universe Peter Parker
facing off against this alternate
reality version of the Rhino and when
Peter shows up the Rhino just kind of
gives up he just sort of walks away and
he's like look at me I'm not facing you
I mean you're the guy who took down
Galactus and that's when things get kind
of crazy because we jump back to the
main university - Parker speaking with
this alternate reality counterpart only
for us to find out that with all the
other superheroes having retired it was
because of the Amazing Spider something
happened somewhere along the line that
this alternate reality version of Peter
Parker became insanely powerful and the
result was that he effectively just
rendered all other superheroes being
completely obsolete now with the main
universe Peter Parker basically
exploring this landscape he ends up
finding out that his Uncle Bill is very
much alive but the downside to this is
that Uncle Ben is pretty cruel now this
is one of the crazy things because when
it comes to Peter's character I mean
this is really kind of common knowledge
but historically Uncle Ben serve the
purpose of Peter becoming the spider-man
that we all know but it was by virtue of
his death does that happen and so we
haven't really seen a whole lot of
alternate reality stories where Uncle
Ben lived it's really been one of those
things that Marvel kind of stays hands
off almost like look you know Uncle Ben
died it's the basis behind Peter Parker
becoming Peter Parker we've seen
alternate reality stories we're like
Aunt May dies instead of instead of
helping Ben but for the most part you
know Uncle Ben's one of those characters
where he died and he stayed dead not
only that this version of Uncle Ben is
extremely cynical and he's actually a
bad guy and the way to be learned this
is because of the fact that the main
Marvel Peter Parker is drinking his tea
Uncle Ben basically makes the statement
that this alternate reality Peter Parker
filled in this alternate reality Uncle
Ben on what was going on and so what we
end up learning is that this alternate
Peter has basically been using the
portal to bring other spider-man to his
universe and in Sakhalin their life
energies killing them off and absorbing
their power in the process and so that's
one of the reasons why the superheroes
in this alternate reality retired
because this alternate version of Peter
basically made himself insanely powerful
he was wildly strong he was fast he was
capable of legitimately beating people
like Galactus and so on and so forth and
so because of that it creates a pretty
interesting scenario because now we end
up having the main Marvel Universe Peter
Parker discovering that this alternate
reality version of Uncle Ben is a bad
guy not only that this alternate reality
Peter is not really a villain he's
trying to do the right thing and he's
trying to be legitimate so again it's
kind of a funny scenario just because of
the fact that when Uncle Ben goes to
attack the main Peter Parker Peter
basically kind of dodges out of the way
and the result is that this alternate
reality version of Peter is in them you
know is that being killed instead so
again it's really kind of a weird moment
and it's kind of strange the way it
unfolds but about your main what we end
up doing is we end up picking up with
Deadpool's part of the story and again
this is kind of cool because Deadpool
comes across this alternate reality
counterpart named death wish and it
pretty much unfolds exactly as you would
expect they just kind of goof off
there's one point where they go to an
aquarium
Deadpool gets his leg bit off and
they're just kind of like yeah man and
they're just having like amazing fun
that it looks like the most fun that
I've ever had in my life now what we end
up learning is that this version of
Deadpool is not who we would expect it
to be we actually end up finding out
this alternate reality version is not
Wade Wilson but before we can get an
answer they're effectively attacked by
Doctor Doom was going by the name death
mask so again it creates kind of this
wild scenario it's actually pretty funny
here because this guy very much speaks
like Doctor Doom that's one of the
things people love most about his
character one of the things that I've
already loved about the character of
Doctor Doom is that he refers to himself
in the third person his cockiness as
hubris but of course in the middle of
all this he basically incinerates death
which in his entirety calling him a
failure and again what this does is it
establishes that there were things going
on on both sides the death mask was
using Death Wish for the purpose of
accessing this teleporter and so again
it's basically a mirror version of all
the events that has happened in the main
Marvel Universe in terms of the events
surrounding this teleporter and so on
and so forth but in terms of infernal
Hulk essentially the reason why you're
here what we end up finding out is that
in this universe Bruce Banner and The
Incredible Hulk are two distinctly
different individuals the basis behind
this discovery actually comes from the
main Marvel Universe Peter Parker coming
through the files of this alternate
Peter Parker and basically finding out
again the reason why all the superheroes
had left and so on and so forth but the
idea that in this universe Bruce Banner
became the sorcerer supreme he was
basically brought under the wing of
Doctor Strange and trained to be the new
sorcerer supreme and so the result is
that he had basically banished the
Incredible Hulk from his body and
effectively sent him to hell porcelain
Deadpool going about his adventures and
you know Deadpool stories being as
nonsensical as they ever worked what we
find out is that this guy death mask is
actually this universe's version of Wade
Wilson you know but essentially what had
happened is that he had suffered from
cancer in the same way the main Marvel
Universe Deadpool had the difference
here is that Reed Richards actually
performed surgery take curative Allman's
cancer because of this wooden being
cured he basically became super
intelligent and then fancied itself a
criminal built an empire dis combined
with the Amazing Spider going through
stealing the power of spider-man
basically meant the various superheroes
retired and death masks had the
opportunity to build up this massive
empire for himself and so of course the
result is that Wade Wilson throws like a
bomb
and we're simple on those lines they
fight for a little bit and this
alternate reality version of Deadpool is
effectively killed off I mean he's more
or less eliminated and so what we end up
doing is we have you know death masks
basically going to hell and then
beseeching up Mephisto now those are
guys who are new to Marvel Comics
Mephisto
is a cosmic entity but he's basically
Satan in the realm of Marvel Comics
there is an actual devil in in Marvel
this is one of the big differences
between Marvel and DC DC takes a very
heavy-handed approach when it comes to
like did judeo-christian themed you find
all that stuff in vertigo with Marvel
it's not that way it's really more of
the idea that different cosmic entities
represent aspects of the universe all
that really stems back to the idea of
the Stanley Jack Kirby era not really
wanting to involve Christian themes and
instead looking at comics as a kind of
escape from reality something to kind of
goof off about but again what this idea
of the Incredible Hulk with the infernal
Hulk essentially what had happened here
is that with this alternate reality
version of Bruce Banner vanishing the
Incredible Hulk persona from himself it
was essentially sent to hell now what it
initially went to hell the Hulk was very
much as we imagined him he was just
green he was large and so on and so
forth but he was basically corrupted by
Mephisto himself now whether that was
through magic or sorcery or
what-have-you is not really explained
instead what is happening here is that
these versions of a banner and Hulk
basically switch and so what ended up
happening is when the main Marvel
Universe Bruce Banner arrived in this
alternate reality because this alternate
version of Bruce Banner basically cast a
spell across the universe that banished
the Incredible Hulk from him when the
main Marvel Universe Bruce Banner showed
up The Incredible Hulk and banner split
and so it was basically a scenario where
as soon as Banner arrived The Incredible
Hulk persona
immediately went to hell and so it
allowed infernal Hulk to switch places
with The Incredible Hulk and the result
is that the infernal Hulk is on earth
and The Incredible Hulk is in hell so
hopefully your brain is nice and nice
and mush by now after that little
explanation I don't know any other way
to explain that but we're really follows
here is just kind of this conflict of
sorts in the sense that infernal Hulk is
basically imbued with the power of hell
the magics of Mephisto combined with is
already incredible and incalculable
strength and that's one of the crazy
scenarios when it comes to the Hulk and
if you go through and start reading
different stories by Marvel Comics
for the most part they don't really
modify be incredible because if they did
he would be insanely okie like you know
exactly what you're seeing right here
and this particular instance we've been
being bonded to the various forms of the
various magic of Mephisto that basically
give him heightened invulnerability and
the heightened level of strength it
basically means that he's essentially
unstoppable and so basically it's this
plan of the sorcerer supreme
Bruce Banner combined with the efforts
of spider-man as well as Deadpool to try
to find a way to pull this out now again
this ultimately leads to Deadpool being
made to look like Bruce Banner to serve
as a distraction while the actual you
know sorcerer supreme Banner and
spider-man try to figure things out but
essentially what happens here is the
Incredible Hulk persona is effectively
retrieved from how basically brought to
face off against its alternate reality
hammer part infernal Hulk and so having
this Incredible Hulk versus the infernal
Hulk concept these two beings battling
one another it sets things in motion
pretty easily now of course with the
power of the Incredible Hulk alongside
the power of Doctor Strange it basically
allows you know the Incredible Hulk to
overcome infernal Hulk pretty readily
but again that's something that we
wouldn't normally see because with the
infernal Hulk I mean you got to remember
he's got the powers of mysticism and
magic and The Incredible Hulk still
pretty strong but at the end of the day
it's really just kind of forcing
infernal Hulk back into the body of the
Doctor Strange version of himself and so
the result is that when that happens
they effectively snap the neck of
sorcerer supreme Bruce Banner killing
his physical body and destroying his
ability to turn back into the Incredible
Hulk and so again it's kind of an
interesting scenario because the
infernal Hulk is just kind of stuck
inside of a dead body now one of the
things that Marvel doesn't really
explain here is exactly how that works
there have been alternate reality
stories where they've dealt with that
and this one they don't and so in order
to provide an explanation we kind of
have to look at some alternate reality
stories I mean for the most part
whenever there was an instance where
Bruce Banner tried to like take his own
life or somebody tried to kill Bruce
Banner The Incredible Hulk persona would
pop up and ultimately save the life
abandoned whether Banner wanted to live
or not the only exception that I can
think of is the Incredible Hulk the end
and in that story Bruce Banner had
basically grown into an old man
following a nuclear holocaust and the
Incredible Hulk being the sole survivor
on earth and the Bruce Banner persona
basically had a heart attack
the mind of Bruce Banner to die and the
incredible hope to just kind of live on
but that's the opposite of what happened
here so the question is would be
incredible health manifest and basically
live you know those are things that
we're not given an answer to instead we
just kind of have to take it for what
it's worth and so ultimately what ends
up happening here because we basically
find out the following the death of
sorcerer supreme Bruce Banner his mind
more or less or his essence or soul or
what have you had left his physical body
and transitioned to hell for a moment
and in doing so basically freed the body
of you know this alternate reality Peter
Parker that was killing all the
alternate universe versions of himself
and was lowering their power and then
bringing them back to earth whereby he
undertakes the mantle of a Ghost Rider
which is kind of cool because now he's a
spirit of vengeance you know destined
basically grab the spirits of bad guys
and take them back to hell and you know
that kind of a thing but again you know
the story ends pretty quickly
you know the portal is basically
reconstructed by this alternate reality
version of Peter Parker as a last gift
you know as trying to make them in
forest 'passed actions and it allows
Deadpool spider-man and The Incredible
Hulk to basically you know travel back
to earth but again not a great big huge
explanation video not a whole lot to go
into you in terms of you know character
concepts and anything it's just kind of
a fun little story kind of a fun little
three-part three-part origin which I
thought was sort of cool if you guys are
interested in this it's actually the
amazing spider-man number 38 a Deadpool
annual number one I think it is from
2011 and then the incredible hulks
annual number one but it's actually a
pretty cool story pretty great little
little tidbit of an adventure
essentially but that's basically the
life the the origin and death of of
infernal Hulk pretty cool little store
anyway guys if you are new here to come
as explained make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the rob
Court if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you guys drop a like and I
will catch you all later please
[Music]